mario empezó el día con cinco flores de
fuego uso algunas y ahora sólo le quedan
tres si es el número de flores que ha
usado podemos escribir la siguiente
ecuación cuántas flores de fuego usó
mario empezó con 5 usó algunas por lo
cual podemos restar ese número y le
quedaron 3 hay varias maneras de hacer
esto y una es que lo hagas mentalmente
piensas que si tenía 5 flores de resto
un número y le quedaron 3 puedes hacer
mentalmente el cálculo para deducir que
tenía que haber usado dos flores otra
manera hacer esto es bueno tienes varias
opciones puedes probar todas estas en
este caso fue fácil el cálculo mental
pero si hubiera sido más complicado
podemos probar las cuatro opciones que
tenemos si hubiera usado cero tendría 5
-0 5 si hubiera usado 1 le quedarían 5
menos 1 igual a 4 si hubiera usado 3 le
quedarían 5 menos tres igualados y al
usar 2 le quedaron 5 menos 2 igual a 3 y
la tercera manera la vas a aprender a
medida que avancemos con nuestro
conocimiento del álgebra aprenderás el
cómo y el por qué y te da
cuenta que esto lo puede resolver
sistemáticamente por medio un
procedimiento preciso pero esto lo
veremos en futuros vídeos así es que el
uso dos flores de fuego